[Music]
i never got to have you on the show this
is great thanks for being here my
pleasure to be here finally glad to meet
you you know
don't watch a lot of tv but i do watch
the news and i'll watch your show
and you kind of got like a newscaster
face so when you're out there telling
your monologue always believe the lies
you'll be saying
you always think i'm telling the truth
so you think the world is really screwed
up if you're listening to me well it's
so great to have you here and i'm just
the only question is why are you here on
valentine's day you know why are you
here with me on valentine's day well i
got a pass for my wife to come hang out
with you so i'm gonna head with you hit
a hand that's nice you got to give me
something to take home though at least
you know to me something to take home i
don't know what i have yeah oh there you
go
all i have is pencils i think andy's
idea is better i don't want to get the
water spilled on yeah but you take that
when you go i was over there dog that
dog wig you had
you want the dog wig yeah the thing you
had with the door hook you up with a dog
wig
i can make that happen all right look
what i got you honey a dog wig
[Laughter]
you better not try that all right are
you a romantic guy are you pretty
romantic i think i'm pretty romantic you
know got to have love in your heart you
know love love makes the everyday go
better man so i'll keep it smooth that's
nice
it's just great the way you did that
i can't i'd be like just love man just
go for it
it's not the same when i do it
um
you're now on uh californication uh i
i've watched that show a bunch of times
it just seems like everybody gets naked
on that show everybody but you you have
not gotten naked on the show yet well so
far they have not asked me to get naked
you know i mean and i'm in shape though
so i don't mind if i had to take it off
i'll probably increase the ratings
but uh that is a show you don't know you
know you'll be on the set and uh it was
one episode uh the guy was standing on a
on a sushi bar butt naked so you got the
raw fish
you got his butt hanging out right there
yeah and uh you got people ordering food
yeah like only on california yeah yeah
yeah and so it hasn't happened yet but
you you're sending out the signal that
you are willing to go nude if it's
required
you know depends on the situation man
but hey i'm gonna say kid all right